we spent some time yesterday talking
about
whether or not it's it's being regarded
as a nick saban but instead of an and
when a guy opted out based on what jerry
jones said earlier this week and also
steelers gm kevin colbert here's sean
mcvay coach of the la rams on the issue
of players who opted out
you don't punish a guy this past year
has certainly been uh
you know i think one that uh is is is
different in so many ways but
you don't punish guys for that you go
back to the tape uh you look at what
they've previously done and then there
are some projections with guys that
maybe have less uh tangible evidence on
the tape and and it all is a part of the
evaluation process but but certainly
nothing weighs more than than when
you're evaluating them playing the game
that we're going to ask them to do
that is a more positive way to put it
the reality is the more of a projection
that's involved
the more it could hurt a guy it's not
about the fact that he opted out it's
the fact that that we are and i think
that may have been what jerry jones was
trying to say exactly right that it is
it is a projection if a guy missed last
year we didn't get to see whether he
continues to develop in a positive way
maybe he would have stunk if he had
played last year we've seen that we've
seen guys enter the process before their
last year in college football cream of
the crop remember brian braum first
overall pick right 2 000 right and 87 7
right 2000 it was 2008 it was the year
that brett favre retired because they
ended up getting him in round three
right he was gonna be the number one guy
played one more year and stunk sorry but
that's what happened right matt barkley
he was gonna be the number one pick
right i mean hey stay in school you're
gonna be the number one pick and he
stayed in school and he wasn't right so
yeah round four yeah um but nonetheless
i'm with you i think that's what jerry
was trying to say
it's it's just cool
it's the thing i respect about sean
mcvay you know he just
being around him
whenever i have and then just the way he
comes off in press conferences he's just
he's a real guy he's a human
and he takes all those things into
account so i respect that about him and
yeah they don't have a lot of picks
they're going to have to make their
picks count for sure in their their
luxury
malibu house this weekend that they're
going to be having fun i hope we get a
few look-ins on that in round one
tonight even though they're not picking
in round one anything to do i know
well i want to stay on a swimming pool
they got a kegerator they're just going
to sit around and drink right i want to
see you smoking yeah sounds good invite
me i'll come out come on
but you know let me say this because
sean mcvay was able to deliver that
message in a way
that
created no ambiguity
and opened no door for anyone to say
yeah but you're also sticking it to
these guys a little bit
for going against the football grain
when jerry said it some of that came
through when mcvay said it it was spun
in the most positive way possible and it
doesn't cast an implicit aspersion on
the player who god forbid chose to go a
year without playing football maybe they
don't love football as much as they need
to maybe they don't submit to the
program the way they should a little of
that came through with jerry it didn't
come through with sean mcveigh no it did
not it did not and you know again i
think you know mcveigh is just um an
unreal communicator that way you know
he's he's a guy that i just got a great
way with players you know even hey even
us anybody i mean anybody that's been
around sean mcvay and if you're there
and it's you know not a huge gathering
you know his ability to communicate talk
be charismatic make you feel you know
like you're important with your
conversation he listens i mean that's
what makes him special yeah he's boy
genius and got the greatest recall in
football and all that type of stuff but
it's also his ability again with that
team they've had a lot of
personalities changing parts all of
those type of things you don't ever hear
an issue in l.a with the rams with any
of that type of stuff and that's because
of sean mcvay he's an incredible leader
and there's no bs in him at all
so you know the players trust him when
they know they can trust him uh with
whatever he says or whatever direction
he's leading the team in
so you're saying he's not exactly like
john gruden
uh no there's no bs in him then no he's
not exactly like john gruden no let me
just say this though since you are
heaping praise and i'm a big sean mcvay
fan yeah i will say this sean mcvay
wants to go
next level
as a communicator the key word sean
modulation that's all i'm saying
modulation speed tone volume modulation
will serve you well
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports